HELLO I'M LYNDA KINKADE LIVE AT
CNN'S HEADQUARTERS IN ATLANTA.
WELCOME TO ONE WORLD IN SUDAN
AND ALREADY DIED. HUMANITARIAN
SITUATION IS DETERIORATING WITH
MILLIONS OF CIVILIANS BEARING
THE BRUNT OF A DEADLY POWER
STRUGGLE. SHELLING AND GUNFIRE
POUNDED HATOUM ON WEDNESDAYS.
RIVAL MILITARY FACTIONS BATTLED
IT OUT FOR 1/5 STRAIGHT DAY. THE
PARAMILITARY GROUP RSF SAYS IT'S
AGREED TO A 24 HOUR CEASEFIRE
SET TO BEGIN RIGHT NOW, BUT SO
FAR THE ARMY HASN'T RESPONDED.
AND IT COMES ONE DAY AFTER THE
COLLAPSE OF A TEMPORARY TRUCE
THAT BOTH SIDES BLAME EACH OTHER
FOR AND MADE THE ACCUSATIONS THE
FIGHTING IS INTENSIFYING,
SENDING SOME CIVILIANS FLEEING
FOR THEIR LIVES. MANY OTHERS
REMAIN TRAPPED IN THEIR HOMES
RUNNING DANGEROUSLY LOW ON FOOD
AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER. ONE
AID AGENCY SAYS HALF OF THE
HOSPITALS IN THE CAPITAL OUT OF
ACTION WELL, CNN'S LARRY MEDORA
JOINS ME NOW LIVE FROM NAIROBI
WITH MORE ON THIS GOOD TO HAVE
YOU WITH US, LARRY. SO THIS IS
NOW THE FIFTH DAY OF THIS
VIOLENT ATTACK WAS SAYING
BETWEEN THESE TWO RIVAL MILITARY
POWERS. AND NOW THAT PROPOSAL
FOR A CEASEFIRE THAT IS MEANT TO
BE UNDERWAY RIGHT NOW,
YESTERDAY'S FAILED. WILL THIS
ONE BE ANY DIFFERENT? LINDA THIS
IS THE THIRD ATTEMPT AT A
CEASEFIRE. IN SUDAN. MAYBE THIRD
. TIME'S THE CHARM. WE JUST
DON'T KNOW HE SHOULD HAVE BEGUN
A FEW MINUTES AGO, BUT YET ONLY
ONE SIDE HAS AGREED TO WITH THE
RAPID SUPPORT FORCES, THIS
POWERFUL PARAMILITARY GROUP THAT
IS IN THIS CONFLICT WITH A
SUDANESE ARMY BECAUSE OF THE
POWER STRUGGLE BETWEEN THE TWO
LEADERS THAT TWO MOST POWERFUL
GENERALS IN SUDAN. THE FIRST
ATTEMPT WAS ON SUNDAY FOR THREE
HOURS THAT DIDN'T WORK OUT
BECAUSE EACH SIDE ACCUSED THE
OTHER OF VIOLATING IT. THAT THE
SECOND ATTEMPT WAS A 24 HOUR
CEASEFIRE BROKERED BY THE US
THAT SHOULD HAVE STARTED
YESTERDAY AT SIX PM LOCAL. IT'S
COLLAPSED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
AND NOW THIS, WHICH ONLY ONE
SIDE HAS AGREED TO, SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE ARE NOT
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THAT. BUT THE
REAL IMPACT OF THIS CONTINUED
FIGHTING IS THAT THE DEATH TOLL
IS INCREASING. 296 PEOPLE HAVE
SO FAR BEEN KILLED AT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION, CITING DATA
FROM THE SUDAN MINISTER OF
HEALTH MORE THAN 3000. PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN WOUNDED, BUT THAT'S
ALMOST CERTAINLY AN UNDERCOUNT
BECAUSE THERE ARE REPORTS THAT
THERE ARE BODIES THAT REMAIN
LYING IN THE STREETS OF CARTOON
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN PICKED
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SAFE FOR PEOPLE
TO GO OUT, AND I NEED TO POINT
OUT THAT THIS IS A POWER
STRUGGLE BETWEEN THESE TWO MEN,
WHICH HAS 40 45 MILLION SUDANESE
PEOPLE. HIT IN THE CROSSFIRE I
WANT YOU TO HEAR FROM THIS
SUDANESE ACTIVISTS, ROSEN AHMED,
WHO SAID LAST NIGHT WAS A HORROR
SHOW. I CAN'T PUT INTO WORDS HOW
MENTALLY DEVASTATING THIS IS OUR
ONLY ASK. AS INNOCENT CIVILIANS
THAT ARE CAUGHT IN THIS
CROSSFIRE. IS FOR THE RSF IN THE
S A F TO STOP. STOP THE WAR!
STOP THE VIOLENCE. FIND THE
GRACE. TO DIALOGUE. ROSEN AHMED
TOLD CNN THAT IN THE HOUR WHEN
THE CEASEFIRE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
GOING ON A MISSILE HIT HER
NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE AND IT BURNED
DOWN. SHE DOES NOT KNOW IF IT
CAME FROM THE SUDANESE ARMED
FORCES ARE FROM THE RAPID
SUPPORT FORCES, AND MOST PEOPLE
DON'T CARE. THEY JUST WANT THE
GUNS TO FALL SILENT AND SO FAR
THAT'S NOT HAPPENED, LINDA YEAH,
WELL, WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
WITH THIS STORY. LARRY MIDO IN
NAIROBI, KENYA. THANKS SO MUCH.
MY NEXT GUEST IS GOING TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FOLLOWERS AROUND THE WORLD AS
THE HITCHHIKING NOMAD. MARTINEZ
IS AN ADVENTURE TRAVELER WHO WAS
IN KHARTOUM WHEN THE VIOLENCE
BROKE OUT, AND HIS VIDEOS HAVE
GONE VIRAL. THIS ONE TAKEN FROM
A DROWN SHOWS A PLANE ON FIRE
THE INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. AND
THIS VIDEO YOU CAN SEE PEOPLE
FLEEING THE CAPITAL CITY BY CAR.
AND ON FOOT. AND THIS MAY PARTLY
EXPLAIN WHY EMPTY SHELVES ARE IN
SUPERMARKETS. PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY
STOP STOCKPILING WHAT THEY CAN.
MAHIN S JOINS ME NOW VIA SKYPE
FROM A ROOFTOP IN KHARTOUM. GOOD
TO HAVE YOU WITH US. I
UNDERSTAND. YOU'VE JUST HEARD
SOME EXPLOSIONS BEHIND YOU. WHAT
ARE YOU SEEING? EXACTLY? WHERE
ARE YOU IN THE CITY. SO RIGHT
NOW I'M JUST NEAR TO THE
CONFLICT AREA JUST ONE KILOMETER
AROUND CONFLICT AREA AND THE
SMOKE IS ACTUALLY COMING FROM
MOST PROBABLY IT'S COMING FROM
THE AIRPORT AND BEACHES LIKE 2.5
, KILOMETERS, SOMETHING FROM
HERE SO IN THE MORNING THERE WAS
A BIG, MASSIVE EXPLOSION MORNING
AND AFTER 41 NOVEL, THERE WAS NO
EXPLOSION OR SOMETHING. BUT
GRAND SHORTS WERE GOING ON THE
SOUND OF, UH, SMALL BOMBING.
THEY'RE GOING ON AGAIN. LIKE
JUST 20. MINUTES AGO, THERE WAS
A MASSIVE BOMBING AND NOW THE
GUNSHOTS AND THE SOUND OF UH AH.
THANK WEEKEND HERE FROM HERE.
AND I UNDERSTAND A US SIMPLY
TRAVELING THROUGH SUDAN WHEN
THIS CONFLICT BROKE OUT OVER THE
WEEKEND, YOU ARE ON A BALCONY.
YOU STARTED FILMING. DID YOU
HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT WAS GOING ON
AT THAT POINT IN TIME, TAKE US
THROUGH WHAT YOU SAW. SO I WAS
NOT HAVING ANY IDEA. I'M HERE IN
SUDAN FROM LAST ONE MONTH, SO I
JUST REACHED IN THE CAPITAL CITY
OF KHARTOUM JUST TWO DAYS BEFORE
THE CONFLICTS CHATTER, SO I WAS
NOT INITIALLY I WAS NOT HAVING
ANY IDEA, BUT LATER ON, I GO TO
KNOW THAT IT'S A CONFLICT
BETWEEN OURSELF AND THE SUDANESE
FORMAL ARMY. AND YOU'VE
OBVIOUSLY BEEN USING THIS THIS
DRONE FOOTAGE OVER THE CAPITAL
TAKE US THROUGH WHAT YOU'VE
CAPTURED. HOW MUCH DESTRUCTION
HAVE HAVE YOU SEEN? HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE YOU WATCHING? FLEE
THE VIOLENCE. UH I'M SORRY. COME
AGAIN. CARRINGTON AGAIN. YOU'VE
TAKEN SOME INCREDIBLE DRONE
VISION OVER THE CAPITAL. CAN YOU
DESCRIBE THIS SORT OF
DESTRUCTION THAT YOU'RE SEEING
AND WHAT'S BEING TARGETED? UH
TODAY. ALSO ACTUALLY, UH, WE
TOOK OUR DRAWN TO AH, FLY THERE
AND MY FRIEND WAS THERE SO
SUDDENLY WE LOST OUR CONTROL AND
WE SEE A MASSIVE, UH SHORT IN
THE ARAB PLANE THAT AIRPLANE WAS
ACTUALLY BURNING THERE. A FEW
PEOPLE ON YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA
SITES. MAHIN ARE WORRIED ABOUT
YOUR WELFARE. IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
HAVE BEEN IN SOME PRETTY
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS WORRIED. UM
SOMEWHAT AM WORRIED, ACTUALLY.
SO I'M FIRST OF ALL APPLE GIVING
APOLOGY FOR MY ENGLISH BECAUSE
I'M NORTHERN ENGLISH NATIVE
SPEAKER. SO ACTUALLY, I'VE BEEN
TO AFGHANISTAN. I'VE BEEN TO
SOME COUNTRIES LIKE DANGEROUS
COUNTRIES. BUT I WAS NOT
WORRIED. LIKE THE LIKE THE WHAT
HAPPENING IN SUDAN RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE A FEW DAYS AGO LIKE I
HAD TO GO OUT ON THE STREET FOR
GETTING SOME WATER HERE. THERE
IS NO WATER AND ELECTRICITY AND
I WAS WALKING JUST 100 M NEAR TO
ME. THERE WAS A GUNSHOT. THEN I
RAN AWAY. YEAH, EVEN PEOPLE. YOU
RAN AWAY. THEN AFTER SOME DAY, I
WAS SITTING SOMEWHERE. THEN THIS
ARMY PEOPLE, THEY CROSS ME AND I
COULDN'T AH, ACROSS MY PATH. I
COULDN'T GO TO MY ROOM. I
COULDN'T REACH MY HOME BACK, SO
I WAS HIDING INSIDE ONE BUSH.
THEN AFTER SOMETHING AGAIN, I
TRIED TO CROSS TO MY PLACE THAN
THIS ARMFULS AND THEY SAW ME AND
THEY TOOK THE GUN OUT. AND THEY
POINTED ON. I MEAN, SO IT WAS
LIKE A TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE. OF
COURSE, I'M WORRIED A BIT. I'M
NOT WORRIED THAT MUCH. BUT STILL
WHEN THIS CASE IS LIKE WHEN I
MEET SOME IMPOSING NEARBY ANY
MASSIVE BOMBING SOUTH WHEN IT
COMES, I'M GETTING, UH AH, A BIT
WORRIED. ACTUALLY THIS IS NOW
THE FIFTH DAY OF VIOLENT ATTACKS
. HOW OFTEN ARE YOU HEARING
ARTILLERY? SO ACTUALLY FROM THE
FIRST DAY FROM THE FIRST DAY I'M
HEARING THE FIRST TWO DAYS WAS
STILL OKAY. BUT FROM THE STORE
THEIR THIRD WAY, THIRD DAY WAS
SO CRUCIAL DAY AND FOURTH DAY.
ACTUALLY IT WAS SOMEWHAT
CRUCIAL. BUT THE FIFTH DAY TODAY
IT WAS LIKE SO LOUD FROM THE
LAST NIGHT FROM THE LAST NIGHT
FROM THE FOURTH NIGHT, THEY
STARTED BOMBING TOO MUCH, AND
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE THE 24 HOURS
OF CEASEFIRE FROM YESTERDAY
EVENING. SIX PM TWO TODAY, EVEN
IN SIX PM, BUT AGAIN YESTERDAY
AT SIX PM THEY INTO DOUBLE LEVEL
ENERGY, ACTUALLY MARINE. ARE YOU
PLANNING TO STAY IN SUDAN, OR
ARE YOU GOING TO TRY TO FLEE?
WHAT'S YOUR PLAN? ACTUALLY I WAS
PLANNING TO GO TO ETHIOPIA FROM
SUDAN WITHIN ONE WEEK, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS HAPPENED BUT
NOW I DON'T KNOW. I WANT TO FLEE
OR I WANT TO BE HERE. THE ONLY
THING I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW I
WANTED TO BE HERE. THAT'S BETTER
THINK, BECAUSE IT'S A CAPITAL
CITY. IF THERE IS ANY EVACUATION
FROM THE GOVERNMENT OF MY
COUNTRY, THEN IT WILL BE TO
BETTER TO STAY HERE. AND IF I
FLEE TO OTHER PLACES, IT WILL BE
SO HARD BECAUSE IN OTHER TOWNS
ALSO, THERE ARE CONFLICT GOING
ON, SO IT'S NOT SAFE. IT'S
BETTER TO BE HERE ANYWAYS, AND
IT'S NOT BETTER TO FLEE. BECAUSE
AS I AS EVER TRAVELER I'M NOT
FROM THIS PLACE. I DON'T HAVE
ANYONE IN OTHER CITIES OR
ANOTHER TOWNS. MCCAIN S WE HOPE
YOU STAY SAFE. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME A